hello everyone and welcome to the start
of the world Blitz Championship here is
a very nice game between yankeesh of
Duda and the Magnus Carlsen Magnus after
winning his uh rapid title now wants to
win his Blitz title as well and he uh
could once again be the holder of all
three titles simultaneously uh he didn't
decline to defend his title as World
classical Champion but he still holds
the title of world classical champion
and if he somehow manages to win the
blitz section as well then he will uh
have uh you know he will have completed
the Triforce and um I don't uh recall if
ever if I mentioned in the previous
video when we were still in Rapid uh
Magnus won the world rapid Championship
second place a place was won by Vincent
kaimer absolutely incredible he almost
got a tie break against Magnus Carlsen
which would lead to a most incredible
match uh and um uh third place was won
by Fabiano Cortana who eliminated uh not
eliminated
in the final round that being said let's
see how the blitz unfolds here we have a
very nice game dude with the white
pieces against Magnus and he opens with
Pawn to D4 we have G6 by Magnus e for
now end in verse chapter G7 Magnus again
going for his modern defense Knight F3
B6 we have knighted uh Bishop to D3 and
now Knight to C6 we have C3 and Knight
to F6 now do that with a very strong
Center and Magnus uh trying to uh well
develop as quickly as possible and will
try to undermine the center later on so
here we have castles castles uh H3 and
now Magnus strikes in the center with E5
we have characters captures uh but not
with the d-pawn Knight captures and E5
we have Knight captures D captors and
just Bishop to E3 nicely continuing
development B6 Magnus wants to finchato
his light score bishop and now there are
some Move games where Bishop the city
was played also Queen to E2 is a non
move but Duda goes Queen to C2 and it is
now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game
uh Magnus social continues development
Queen to E7 you know that the Rook is
coming to D1 so definitely makes sense
we have Knight to D2 Rook to d8 uh and
now Rook F the D1 we have pawned the A5
Magnus starts grabbing space on the
queen side and the bishop to G5 with H6
Bishop to H4 and now Bishop to E6 so now
just putting pieces on optimal squares
uh we have Ponta A4 uh sorry Pawn to A4
by Duda not allowing magnets to strike
with A4 and now Queen to C5 we have
Knight to B3 attacking magnus's queen
queen back to C6 and now Pawn to F3
really uh cementing that e for pawn and
now Magnus can decide between two viable
uh plans or maybe even three one is to
go something like G5 Bush moves in the
Knight H5 and put the Knight on F4 and
the other one is maybe to put the rook
and B8 uh and uh well maybe maybe try to
make some sort of a breakthrough there
but Magnus goes for the third option
which is Bishop to C4 and and okay Duda
says let's trade nothing wrong with
trading captures captures Rook the D2
preparing to double up on the D file so
of course Magnus trades we have
characters Knight characters kicks away
the queen queen to C6 and now Knight to
F1 for those of you who don't know
um in Blitz section there is uh also a
two second increment per move so you
never run out of time we have Rook to d8
and now Knight to E3 an excellent Square
for dude as Knight with Bishop to f8 now
Magnus wants to reactivate the bishop
via this diagonal and now Knight to D5
uh of course now you cannot capture as
the rook and the 8 would hang so Bishop
to C5 check we have King the H1 and now
G5 this is how Magnuson pins but Duda
just trades off one more piece knight
captures on F6 would check Queen
captures and now Bishop back to E1 and
okay now uh magnus's Bishop is a bit
stronger than uh then do this bishop and
also Magnus goes Queen to B6 making sure
that do that cannot play Rook to D1 so
Magnus has the control of the D file he
has the beautiful bishop and this
diagonal and he does have a lot of
potential for pushing the king side
pawns and maybe going for some sort of
an attack so Duda goes B4 as one always
should with Bishop to E3 and now Queen
to E2 yeah putting pressure on the
bishop and now Queen to D3 it would be a
pretty big mistake if you played Bishop
F4 it seems like you're controlling a
lot of squares here but the G3 just
eliminates the bishop and you resign
here so Magnus goes for a queen trade
first Duda decides okay let's trade
captures captures they were both now
extremely low on the clock and they were
basically playing on increment B
captures an A5 B captures and pawn to H
for now uh Magnus says all right Pawn to
C5 we have Pawn to C4 and now Bishop to
D4 puts pressure on The Rook here Rook
to C1 and Rook to A3 Magnus says let's
trade our our a pawns here so Bishop
captures an A5 Rook captures an A4 and
now there of the d8 we have Bishop to E3
now attacking The Rook uh Rook the C3
attacks the bishop and now Bishop to F4
and already Duda has to worry about some
checkmating threats with Rook to A1
Checkmate so King the G1 and now Bishop
to G3 uh there is a I will mention it
because uh like I said players were
already playing an increment here but G
captures on H4 is a is a great option
for black the problem is if Bishop
captures an H4 is played uh White can
just resign look at this spectacular
series of moves Rook A1 check King to F2
and now the incredible Bishop to D2 with
an attack on the rook and the threat of
Bishop E1 check picking up the bishop on
H4 so one you would have to give up the
exchange here because if you play
anything else just uh Bishop to E1 check
and you lose the bishop on H4 so if
Magnus wanted he could capture the pawn
but Bishop to G3 this doesn't really
waste any time for him now the F2 and H2
squares are covered and again Magnus is
threatening check Checkmate so Rook the
C1 blocking this and now G captures an
H4 and okay Magnus is up a pawn but it's
still a doubled H Pawn uh perhaps Duda
can still fight this and with King to F1
he most certainly can however he plays
Bishop to B6 here puts pressure on the
C5 pawn and now there is one move that
allows Magnus to win the game and it's
possible only due to a specific
placement of dudas pieces which is
pretty much the case in any position but
I don't know it just felt like this uh
uh was something I should say uh so you
know yeah what are you gonna do yeah but
yeah feel the uh feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the only
winning idea for Magnus uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible series of moves and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to F4 and that's the
that's the move now we will re-maneuver
the bishop here and then the king will
be forced either to H2 or the king will
be forced all the way uh to the center
of the board which will mean that the
white king will be unable to help out
with the defense of the king side so
Duda decided to go for Rook to C2 now
comes Bishop to E3 check uh King to H2
and now Rook the A1 and this is now uh
unplayable for white uh so aduda goes
Bishop to d8 it's even the top move
recommended by the engine going after
the H4 Pawn but Magnus just shows that
it is impossible to do anything about it
Bishop F4 check we have King to H3 and
now even H5 showing that if you capture
an H for now then Rook to H1 is
Checkmate and capturing with the King
also doesn't help as a rook to H1 is
still real Checkmate the bishop and pawn
are doing a great job here of covering
the G file so after H5 G3 Duda has to
give up another Pawn to create some
breeding room for the king but this
means that Magnus now fixes his Pawn
structure and is up two pawns and that
is of course more than enough to win the
game King G2 now comes King to G7 now
Magnus will bring the king into the game
for the pawn to H4 and then at some
point even to H3 with Bishop to E7 uh
King to G6 we have Rook to B2 and now
Rook the C1 Magnus even will put
pressure on the C4 pawn bishop captures
on C5 and now H4 uh King to H3 stopping
that H Pawn now comes Rook to H1 check
and if you go to G2 Rook H2 check picks
up the rook and B2 so of course The Duda
has to go up the board he plays King to
G4 but now the elegant H3 there is no
stopping G2 now Rook the B6 check was
played F6 and even Bishop to E7 to win
the F6 spawn but it is it is uh well
futile
you know at the least so here G2 Rook
captures an F6 with check King to G7 and
it was in this position on a move 54
that young should have Duda resigned the
game as there is no defense against the
G1 Queen uh once this happens you you
resign the game you can give up the
bishop with Bishop to C5 but also I mean
you're gonna be down a piece no point in
playing that uh so yeah uh that's uh
that was a very nice win by by Magnuson
so far
and I'm recording this uh at around 10
games already having been been played uh
it is currently a race between Magnus
and Hikaru both of them with six wins
and three draws uh they've drawn their
game uh that they played together it was
a fairly quick draw not a lot of fun
happening there uh so we'll see what
happens uh they decided to draw against
each other and then they will try to
crush as uh I imagine they see it as a
lesser opposition uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I will
keep you updated if uh Magnus will be
able to to you know complete the
Triforce or will maybe Maxine be able to
defend his title as a world Bliss
Champion or will someone uh maybe do
both or someone who is really really
fighting well in both tournaments maybe
take the crown uh so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Michael hope Consulting I mean uh
karania Mark Abbott Robert taraton and
the Michael zacarias for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day